[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
the one thing the internet has been
missing since circa 2014 and that's
people talking about a ghostbusters
movie yes yeah that's right
buckle up uh we're doing it again um
because they keep making them uh on
australia commentary for ghostbusters
afterlife uh i'm here with vaughn and
danielle well we'll give you our our
deepest darkest thoughts about the film
uh show you some deleted scenes and then
tease you with uh the honest trailer uh
that's coming up next week along with
taking your comments and questions so
keep those going in the chat
um let's just do cards on the table what
we thought overall about about gba uh i
will begin
i think that this was a
perfectly good
children's movie okay in the kids on
bikes genre
but that continues to be baffling to me
just because i think it it depends on
your original relationship with
ghostbusters and my my relationship with
ghostbusters is that it's like a
goofball snl comedy like caddyshack or
the three amigos or something like that
so to me it's baffling in the sense that
like what if they made a movie where
like you know rodney dangerfield's great
grandson finds like an old dusty putter
in the attic
and they'll get on fights
i think we all know this is going to
happen we're all going to be like
these kids are going to have to find a
gopher or something like it's coming
yeah yeah wait we have to go we have to
go back to school and it's just like a
bunch of kids like well we're already in
school like making sandwiches out of
like uh hors d'oeuvres or whatever so
yeah
so i like this movie more than the 2016
one i enjoyed it a lot more and yet i do
think that getting some snl comedians to
just goof around in a ghost themed
series of sketches is what the original
was basically so it's just a it's just a
weird place to take it but hey people
love it so um what do you guys think of
of afterlife uh not for me but that's
okay not all movies have to be for me uh
this was definitely one that was like uh
not not i just i don't
i think i'm really burnt out on and we
talk about this in the thing and we'll
get into it when we do it i'm really
burnt out on you like this here's this
and i know we all like quote like the
member berries but this was nothing but
member berries and it's like i do know
that movie i have both of them memorized
until you give me you know
a child dancing to on your own or on
their own like uh doing a little doing a
little bobby brown that why wasn't
millie bobby brown in this and then we
could have gotten really bobby brown to
do the bobby brown song like that's so
for me
i said it's fine i know a lot of people
who literally said it made them cry and
that's dope i i think that that's great
for me i got very burnt out on again
like it's the thing that i always liked
about ghostbusters the thing i love
about this property is that they are
essentially ghost plumbers and these are
a bunch of uh cosplaying kids and that's
adorable and i love that for you if that
is the thing that you were into we were
talking about before uh we went on air
again other shows that we could we could
do this where it's like oh everything's
the kids on bikes now i would you know
if they made a kids on bikes coming to
america i'd watch it
yeah i mean they did see i think that
that was i i had mixed feelings
it wasn't the kids on bike certification
of coming to america but they did make a
sequel and it's like it was funny i mean
there are some scenes in there where it
almost becomes a kids on button yeah
exactly like the funny part for when
they treated it like a sketch movie and
like just do the barbershop sketch again
like that part was funny but then when
they treat it like oh this is the legacy
sequel of comedy movies i just it just
doesn't connect for me it's a a round
peg square hole it's just
ghostbusters is funny i i talked to i'm
not going to call anyone up in it i was
talking to a friend who liked this a lot
more than i did i thought this was
terrible i was wondering
i'm a picture guesses as soon as we get
off as a fan of the original two movies
i thought this was a disaster but i i
was speaking to somebody who liked it a
lot better and they were explaining that
they're younger than me and for them
ghostbusters is not just those two
movies it's a video game it's that
animated series the real ghostbusters
which i did also watch uh and it's it's
there's other ghostbuster media and this
was like everything they're nostalgic
for the world of ghostbusters and this
recapture that in a new context and i
and i guess i do understand it from that
perspective for me ghostbusters the
original it's a great comedy it's a
movie i love because it was so funny and
because i love the perspective and the
humor of those characters and so
removing that context and re-setting it
in some oklahoma town among the bunch of
stranger things rift kids and taking the
comedy out and just making it this
homage to the mythology
it makes no sense to me it's just it
just feels like it's remember a guy over
and over again remember this guy
remember that thing remember this line
and sometimes
bafflingly removed of context like egon
has spray-painted that bible quote in
front of his farm where it's like the
seas boiled judgment day he wasn't even
in the car when ray and winston were
quoting that in the original movie how
would he even know they were making that
reference it's like the context doesn't
matter it's just remember this from the
other one and i don't i don't care i can
just go back and watch the other one i
like sincerity like i don't want to
because i i always i'm a huge fan of
sincerity in my comedy i've talked about
this i love parks and rec i love those
things where it gets a little shmoopy i
like hugging and learning but i do i do
think that it is a little odd when you
take these things that are clearly like
yes they have mythos yes they have
obviously like a plot because it's a
movie and thankfully they used to do
that
um
so it has all of those things like we
used to get those in our comedies it was
really nice but it does kind of feel a
little weird to
prop up this comedy as like do you
remember the the great mythos of the
ghostbusters sits down children and let
me tell you about it it does feel a
little um
i don't know i don't know that
everything necessarily needs to be
sealed up in a tomb you know much like
uh
yeah
we can stop making things people don't
seem to realize that
it's okay to stop
but i i don't think you need to stop
making ghostbusters that concept as a
comic platform has a lot you could keep
doing it like i i don't mind the 2016
one as much as other people not all the
jokes work i agree there there's some
stuff that doesn't work about it but i i
thought
it worked better than this because it
was the same
rough concept it's funny people and
their sort of blue collar approach to it
and their busting goes and i think you
could keep making those for years i just
yeah like you don't need to they're
they're
they're focusing so much on this
sumerian babylonian gozer zul mythology
and like who cares that's just the
throwaway stuff in the first one and
even in the second ghostbusters movie
like they came up with a different ghost
and a different ancient legend and a
different mythology and it's like yeah
tying this all the evo chandor like
that's super meaningful and we want to
meet evo shandor it's like that's a
silly name dan akroyd made up you don't
have to homage not silly to dan
aykroydlon ifochandor is real and he's
the reason that aliens have not visited
us yet i mean that was the original
script that accurate had conceived for
ghostbusters was way more mythology
heavy and then they smartly realized the
late great ivan reitman uh part of the
equation very smartly realized oh wait
that's not the important stuff that's
just the set dressing these these guys
the chemistry and the jokes yeah the
jokes and venkman and rey and winston
and egon together
and rick moranis like that's the movie
the mythology is just the the decoration
and i think this one kind of mixes that
up
well let's dive into the honest trailer
i'm sure we'll have more to say along
those lines
[Music]
from the studio hanging on by a spider
thread and the guy who made the 1984
classic skid comes a film that invites
you to remember how great the original
was
and that's it that's the whole movie
ghostbusters afterlife
you'd love the ghostbusters when they
look like chainsmoking janitors thrilled
when they became saturday morning
cartoons and reacted in a totally calm
proportionate matter when they were
recast as women they're making
ghostbusters with only women what's
going on wonder how many times we can
use this book instead of making it
make you feel
good sony will give you a two hour long
bj to your nostalgia for a second just a
quick pause i'm sorry
how many celebrities because isn't
is dan aykroyd one of the celebrities
who has gone on record to say that they
have boned a ghost oh really wait i
didn't know he what
no cash uh i believe you're referring to
well there's no pressure she's had sex
with a guy
there have been a few
celebrities who have said they've phoned
a ghost it's a trooping
i remember the question the kesha thing
because a lot of people made dan
acquired in ghostbusters reference i
don't know if akroid really believes in
ghost or if he's more alien focused he's
more of an alien dude but i think he's
just all in on everything paranormal
which is like yeah you know it it's cute
and kooky when you're rich but when he's
like
lucy lou your neighbor
oh right yes there wasn't lucy i
remember that too uh dan aykroyd um
pas de la
oh that makes all the sense in the world
right yeah kesha yeah
um
someone named coco austin unfamiliar
with their work that's iced teas wife oh
coco oh is that coco coco
why are we giving her our last name
or whatever it is yeah
and natasha blasik of paranormal
activity two
uh there you go
yeah a lot a lot of people begging
all of our sanest and most grounded
celebrities
uh surprise no demons the only one on
there that's like uh yeah lucy who's the
only one where i'm like really lucy you
don't have to do this
uh that's a different video all right
let's keep watching the trailer for the
original that's so desperate to wash up
the stank of their last attempt by the
end they drop afterlife from the title
as if to say you want ghostbusters here
we made ghostbusters again happy now
travel to somerville oklahoma a location
that honors the original's roots by
being secretly canadian it's one of
those small towns that becomes a big
town whenever there's a car chase and he
was home to the late scientist egon see
right when your favorite character
started the ghostbusters he also
abandoned his family sorry that's kind
of now
yeah what i know we talk about it later
but it's like what is and isn't canon
and what did and didn't happen
in this movie is very perplexing to me
like and
granted ghostbusters 2 does this also
but it's like
ghosts came out of the earth and haunted
new york and there was a large
marshmallow
two doesn't have people forgot that it
happened i guess in a very
in a you know like a kind of realistic
way it just like it stopped happening
and people were like ah it wasn't that
big of a deal they didn't yeah we're
over it that much like it was like 15
minutes of fame yeah like it was one of
those things where it's like you know
that year
you know uh ghost busting uh in
ghostbusters 2 was the nfts of that year
where it's like yeah everyone was seeing
ghosts this is my ghost this is my ghost
you can't copy face this ghost it's my
ghost and then you know like a year
later everyone's like remember ghosts
god that was right and that is if go
stop being as prevalent people would get
cynical about it right away it's just
like how real people had to like
work very hard to prevent y2k from
happening but now if you mention y2k
everybody's like that didn't even happen
that was dumb it's like no it had like
the same thing would happen with ghosts
but
i agree with you that's ghostbusters 2.
i agree with you on this movie where
people forgot that it happened even
though you can pull up youtube videos of
ghosts in new york and it's like i don't
know i think we would have it is also i
guess it's also a continuing
ghostbusters tradition of when people
learn that ghosts exist their reaction
is like whoa
it doesn't like change their life
it's like oh whoa a ghost okay what are
we gonna do
like go surreal i feel very strongly
that if someone uh walked down the
street as the statue of liberty to a
soul song
that it would be a thing that like you
would remember you might make fun of it
um there would probably be like a few uh
uh tasteless video games or things like
that like as the tragedy happened
because people didn't have to die yeah
there's no way people didn't die during
that excuse they're exclusive to the
movie he's like well these are kids they
weren't alive yet it's like they weren't
alive for 9 11 either but they know that
it happened
it depends which youtube channels
they're watching um i mean yeah right
maybe if they believe that but i guess
the podcast might not yeah podcast might
not well that's the thing is like the
the stature of of egon in this future is
like he's either one of the ghostbusters
that stopped the ghost invasion or he's
like some strange old dirt farmer that
nobody seems to know who he is or what
he's up to like get off the lawn
yeah it's a small town you'd be like oh
we've got a local celebrity this was a
ghostbuster like check out amazon look
uh dave chappelle still goes to all of
his like small town um as we've learned
all of his
council meetings it's true he got used
to going to be like no low affordable
housing i'll move my dirt farm right out
of here no more busting in this town
didn't recognize because he always kept
his face just hidden by shadow just
upstairs you can see the side you could
see the gray hair but you couldn't see
the face crucial
all right let's keep going embark on a
new journey with the next generation of
spangler when they move into his old
trap house this isn't a farm
it's a trap like his daughter kelly who
hates her dad so much it extends to the
abstract concept of science i just have
uh an allergy to science what are you up
to experiments ugh lame trevor a dirtbag
who spends the summer trying to reverse
joe beta townie you're 15. i'll be 16 in
february and mckenna grace's star turn
as phoebe you may remember her as young
tanya harding young captain marvel
young malignant young emma from ones
young hill house or opposite young
sheldon but now she's all grown up to
play well basically young egon i'm a
scientist and while her grandpa's
awkward jokes got balanced by two comedy
legends phoebe will get hung out to dry
like a first timer and an open mic why
should he never trust
i think this was a
cruel decision but the movie to be like
okay we've got our egon
now
our rey and our venkman
we'll figure that out later but we've
got our ego
yeah the kid crew it was it was her and
then the teenagers were completely
sidelined except for her yeah can we get
a kid who loves podcasts and then one of
the stranger things oh god
i don't know
some weird creep we'll figure it out
later it honestly feels like they wrote
down like he's just kind of a weird
creep and then they never revised this
note at all it's a lot of eye rolling
and i can't
you
in in your comedy if someone makes a
funny joke and it doesn't work then yes
you have to have a ping pong off of
other people it can't just be everyone
else going
ooh brother
it does i mean the
she
purposefully loves we're gonna make a
huge movie long thread of her she loves
bad jokes
on some level it feels like you just
want an excuse to write a bunch of not
read good jokes and like and honestly
they're not even original
yeah
famously bad they're like bad jokes
everybody already knows bad jokes and
like puns and it's just like it's like
the rock and jungle cruise they're like
yeah it's like like crap uh like uh back
when people used to read books and you
would keep them by the toilet like those
like dads you
thousand and know like
to read on the toilet or like whatever
you know yeah i i mean they're like i
don't i don't know the details of how
this movie was developed or the
development process i don't want to say
this is true or not this feels though
like a script that was written very
quickly there's like a lot of threads
that kind of don't get pulled all the
way through and like stuff that just
kind of is abrupt like they they get
kicked out of their home
on the same day that they inherit a new
home from a relative they barely knew
and it's like just in time for the kids
to start school on the first day and
then like paul rudd's got this like
backstory where it's like he's a teacher
but he's kind of there for this other
reason and he's a secret seismologist
and then we never follow through on any
of that and then plus stuff like an
excuse to just fill in gaps with bad
jokes purposefully instead of writing
good jokes it just all feels like we got
to just crank this out we got two weeks
to get a ghostbusters move yeah i don't
know if it didn't seem like rushed it
just seemed like it's not i mean they're
not working with like three or four of
the greatest comedic minds of their
generation
you can plug any plot hole in when the
jokes are yeah exactly ghostbusters is a
sloppy movie but it doesn't matter
there's no excuse for nobody having
funny lines like carrie kuhn and paul
rudd are funny
yeah why don't they have funny things to
say or do you know carrie [ __ ] that is a
thankless role she is just like that
what a waste of a carey
harry kuhn is funny right now in the
gilded age and it's not even a comedy
show yeah
all right let's keep going why should
you never trust adams
because they make up everything
that's funny no it's not what do you
call a dead polar bear
anything you want i can't hear you now
wow
that's funny i just thought you were
being obtuse
was that a geometry joke yes that's why
i winked ah
see if we keep pointing out the jokes
are bad then we're actually being clever
come on not a single bar there better be
a bar
that's funny fine forget it how about
the word podcast that's a funny word
right and podcast why do people call you
podcast
i call myself podcast because of my
why aren't you laughing
legend dan aykroyd returns because he
learned nothing from his other legacy
sequel in fact the whole classic
ghostbusters lineup has been bribed out
of retirement and just like egon they're
saddled men who stopped being friends oh
we could barely keep up our mortgage
some actor bought up most of tribeca and
we lost the firehouse fun
but because rick moranis is saving
himself for one last honey i blew up the
paycheck paul rudd is the new yutz who
gets possessed you don't want to be here
i don't want to be here either watch him
test at the theoretical limits of his
own charm because now he's killed the
time i think kevin pointed this out but
it was too late to work it in is that uh
rick moranis and paul rudd both famous
for shrinking
oh that's good
get me we can't get miranda's back who
else should be another small guy
who's the smallest guy in hollywood
someone else who gets really tiny uh
anyway
you know and i do i love paul rudd but
uh
you can't just throw some rud at it
especially because i do feel like a lot
of
his charm is when you specifically write
things for him or when you let him get a
little improvi and i feel like not all
of that was in there i liked red i i
like him he was fine yeah i was never
um
really uh groaning or rolling my eyes at
his scene so i feel like that's an
accomplishment in this movie i will say
the one scene that i thought felt a
little bit ghostbustersy like the one
moment where they really captured some
of the actual vibe and spirit of the
original is the
at walmart when he's running away from
the like monster terror dog or whatever
and it's like crashing through the
aisles and he's terrified running away
trying to get to his car like that feels
like that scene with moranis where the
the dog is after him like it's one of
the few moments where i really feel like
stylistically and visually like they
actually managed to recall the first
movie rather than just referencing it
oh okay this feels ghostbustersy rather
than just be like hey look this is from
ghostbusters remember that it's from
ghostbusters you idiot
ecto goggles am i right please clap all
right keep going yeah that was just not
the time for flirting my dude the only
thing lurking inside here is my slowly
dying soul is that what that smell is my
life is a dumpster fire i love dumpster
fires i'm bleeding why am i bleeding um
you headbutted a park bench all right
yeah
hi
and a touching tribute to how not even
the dick can find
to lift the proton pack one last time
you know what that was actually a really
sweet moment
oh he's uh he's still here
uh
guys he's not going away
is he gonna say anything
no
should we uh yeah so
the morality of casting somebody who has
no uh consent over whether they'll
appear to film or not um
i did think that like you a lit a little
bit of this goes a very long way and
it's like just the shot of him like
helping her out at the end
that's
as far as this goes okay and then he
just lingers
he's riffing or they're they're riffing
next to him but he's not saying anything
because like i guess they wouldn't cross
that uncanny valley of having him speak
right although they probably could
synthesize something i i bet if they
wanted to pay the whoever did the mark
hamill voice for for boba fett if they
felt like paying that guy they would
have had him say something it was
probably budgetary yeah i don't know i
think that a lot of the uh uh distaste
for this movie um comes less from the
movie itself and more from like the
trends that it's symbolizing yes which
is just like
reference topia and
um uh
deep fakes of dead actors
and like
it's the nadir of those like it i don't
i can't think of a worse
it can get worse
uh i mean theoretically in the future
yeah
let's be honest but he's not referencing
anything anyone cares about like
well if we're gonna put parameters on it
yeah like
yeah it's just the force awakening of
everything where it's just you take
anything people used to love and you
just you just strip mine it for anything
people have any positive feelings for
and then you you talk about handing it
off to the next generation but they're
just there to look back at the old
generation and gawk and look at how cool
exactly this new generation doesn't have
a ghostbusters story of their own it's
literally them picking the bones clean
of the 80s version and it's like
if you really want to relaunch the
franchise give them their own mission
give them their own mythology it's just
such a wasted opportunity
but make sure they all have a penis
otherwise not yeah they're not my
ghostbusters
and balls is part of it
i mean
even though i think like the 2016
conceptually it was like more right
canon yes i didn't sir
uh the 2016 one also made this same
mistake of trying to like yep repackage
like oh the big ghost to the end looks
like the logo and like you don't have to
do that give them their own nemesis you
know
yeah
maybe next time maybe next time
keep going dimmer
so gather into the station wagon for a
film that treats the original it's like
a holy text even though it came out
a note about the uh the that we keep
showing the ghost dome uh for every
every interstitial
for people who say it's excessive maybe
um to me it's one of those things that's
funny and then not funny and then funny
again after you keep doing it but the
point that i was hoping would come
across is like
is this your god like this is the movie
that it's based off of yeah it's just a
reminder that this was what could and
would happen in the original
ghostbusters it was silly and goofy and
raunchy and this movie is
none of those things so that's the
there's a deeper point to the ghost dome
that we keep coming to yeah uh anyways
keep going even though it can't make up
its own mind whether anyone's heard of
them how do you of all people not know
about this i'm ashamed
you know what this means right
your grandfather was a ghostbuster but
whatever this isn't for people who want
another goofy snl movie with cool props
this is for people who want a big budget
music and callback festival where the
easter eggs are the size of denver
omelets so screw it let's just give the
loudest people on the internet what they
really want two straight hours of
references
i love this song so much
great sound to like great sound perfect
this is a
my first appearance in an honest trailer
i'm one i dub myself saying references
and keymaster
oh there was a great earthquake
the sun became as black
the moon
was blood
who are you going to call
breaking wood this place is great
[Music]
shot for shot too the whole movie
it's a five-pointed star
welcome to baskin-robbins would you like
to try our mango fruit blast
is paul rudd like the person sponsored
by that happens i think he signed like a
personal deal yeah movies i appear in i
will put this in all of my movies yeah
weird call back
um yeah anyone should have been
mcdonald's really like it should have
been mcdonald's
well
why because of his mac and me uh
yeah
anyone who knows more about the paul
rudd baskin robbins hookup uh let us
yeah i want to know all right keep going
let's finish this up
starring
the left goesers just a teenage dirtbag
baby
gone can i get a printout of mr
gruberson smiling
huh literally save america
jk splittings
josh gaddube providing the grunts and
squeals of muncher though craft minions
i shot the sheriff rolling a day two
tops how ray you ain't gonna the answers
man two minutes of bill murray as a tree
now to the congo legacy sequel egon ft
casita
and a moment of silence for ivan reitman
so yeah pause sorry that interrupting
the moment of silence that's in the
actual trailer uh but an actual uh uh
just pause to uh say that adam rightman
was so incredible that his
goofy comedies keep getting remade as
like sacred texts
20 years later i mean truly one of the
all-time great writer producer uh cetera
um
that uh
did form a lot of people's childhood um
just for me that happened to be stripes
instead of ghostbusters so
i celebrate the entire catalog but how
amazing are you as a director when even
like none of the tweets like none of the
obit headlines even included stuff like
twins or kindergarten cup or dave all
these great movies he made because he
made they made so many classics you
can't even like fit them all into one
remembrance it's really amazing life
god we should all be so lucky like i
wish that like i pass away and i have
like that legacy of this instead it's
just gonna be me saying meat cannon over
and over again well that's pretty good
said meat
[Laughter]
uh god bless her all right uh keep going
rest in peace
ghostbusters please don't get angry this
time
maybe i could check it out sometime
a flash drive you gotta cast a podcast
little dude it's right there in your
name
yeah come on i mean unless this movie
takes well no because this movie has to
take place in the present day so
whatever
uh
they like the cute flash drive they
wanted him to have that and so they were
like ah forget the logic of podcasts or
casts and it was kind of cute because
she did kind of sell that moment as like
why are you what what is this like why
are you giving me this you know
um
any who let's uh let's do some deleted
scenes i think we cut some stuff from
here
and the guy who made the 1984 classic
skid comes a movie about forgiving your
dad because he left you to hang out with
the ghostbusters
wish i got babies to do therapy just
ghostbusters
obviously this is written before after
approximately midnight
scary [ __ ]
star spangler girl
the woman in the house across the path
from the ghost in the barn wolfhard with
a vengeance manger things
baby driver
egon girl the haunting of farmhouse
bad teacher
rudd simple
size matters not
dog man
now mr gruberson i can get into
slo rogan
av scrub the last podcast on the left
slummer
boo berry
the musa next monster
josh gad as himself
basically gremlins on loan from the wes
anderson collection hudson stock and
what white privilege looks like
she didn't mean it you want to spend the
night my joe
she pulled a gun on a cop remember the
ghostbusters
not scary farm
buster babies
the ballot of buster hugs
goonies never say undead
paranormal captivity
buried with children
you know i like that they basically made
this into the goonies meet stranger
things but it's based on an 80s bro
comedy so the key master and the
gatekeepers still have to get it on
if a dork uh it doesn't make it with a
lady while uh possessed and and no
visitor from the spirit world goes down
on any gentleman then uh it is not my
ghostbusters and publish
and publish which is what i say every
time i send an email
all right let's get into the fan
questions because there have been a lot
as we've been yakking on uh first of all
trevor reese here's a quick one why are
you wearing a brian kessinger star wars
calvin and hobbes shirt i am yeah it's
uh it's calvin hobbs but as hot and
chewy there you go yeah those are two
things i like so i clapped when i saw
them um
i let's see uh evan j
uh fj pretzels what other ivan reitman
movie do you want his son jason to make
a more serious sequel to i say dave or
evolution
uh kindergarten cop would be the one
where it's just like a badass cop movie
with schwarzenegger's character from
that and it has nothing to do with being
a teacher oh well see i want twins
because i want it to be like that thing
of where they're going back and
rediscovering their heritage and like
how sad it was that they never got to be
around each other and really the tragedy
of what happens when one person gets all
the good genes and the other person gets
all of the leftovers or whatever there
are
there's like drama
in all of his well all good comedies
that work as dramas first um but you
could you could do one for stopper my
mom will shoot for sure
i think i've told this story before i
have to tell it again yep so the only
reason i know that stopper my mom will
shoot as a thing is because we used to
long story short um have a bunch of um
just random video cassettes of like
movies that we would like double tape
from um renting them and so on the same
tape as stopper my mom will shoot which
was first
was basic instinct which was second and
danielle was learning some things about
herself and so and so i've seen a lot of
the end of stuff for my father
classic it's classic moving yeah
let's see um
well para a pericles dragon balls asked
what movie if any would you like to see
get a legacy sequel um is there anything
you would like to have like the request
the handoff of the baton to the next
generation doesn't even have to be a
comedy
i mean like they're just we don't have a
great track record on this especially
with with you know like
now that like if we're going back to the
stuff when i was a kid though those
people are very old now so i kind of ha
hackers
hackers could be fun yeah however that
works now
yeah hmm
i mean
yes oh i i've got one uh i would still
like to see i believe russell crowe and
paul bettany could still go back and do
a master and commander follow-up now
that's been they're still making them
they're well there's
right there's always talk there's a lot
of books and there's always talk about
doing another captain jack aubry
movie based on a different one of the
books but i don't know if they're going
to necessarily bring back crow and uh
and bet and that's what i would say i'd
be into it
like i feel like every every generation
could get its own office space like as
work culture changes although i guess
that was like the it was office space
and then it was the office but
now it could be
something else like a mic judge
workplace comedy with you know michael
bolton in it he's doing king of the hill
and beavis and butthead again why not
office yeah why not another office space
oh let's pass the baton to a new beavis
and butthead
well
but this time they're later back and
doing more favors about it
uh speaking of which uh mate valencia
which female lead movie do you want to
see an all-male reboot
don't talk about me like i'm not here or
if you're not telling me that timothy
chalamet could not completely do the the
julia robert's role at that leg he could
definitely do that that was a that was
an interesting film
[Laughter]
wow what a female ensemble film
uh let's just see two dudes do carol
let's just see two guys fall in love
over a lost glove in the in the 50s yeah
you could yeah
maybe bound
yeah
who who's the joe pantaliano so what
woman plays the joey pants yeah the joey
pants give me the male fronted bound
that's the real oh gosh yeah
black swan honestly carrie [ __ ] maybe
yeah
yeah she could be terrifying
um
louise oh fred ted and louis
you said steel magnolias i was actually
i always get these two movies confused
uh i was thinking fried green tomatoes
you could do an all-male fried green
tomatoes that would be a very
very strange pick i could watch it just
like two dudes feeding each other red
fried green tomatoes and then and then
eating a dude or oh god
you have to be eating a woman weird
let's move on uh when to go uh 2864 fps
uh what's the best ice cream flavor and
why is it mango fruit blast are you a
basket plant too yeah wow that's very
specific
i like it as always finds out they even
found out we were uh well i'm personally
partial i don't have a personal
sponsorship but like the ben jerry's
stuff where they just throw like an
entire bag of candy in there like i like
i like like a cold stone creamery like a
lot of toppings mixed into like a
vanilla but like with oreos and
uh m ms and whatever else you have lying
around like that's my favorite type of
ice cream yeah i'm like all into uh um i
am all into like a froyo experience like
if you take experience
yes you take this girl to a yogurt land
and she's pretty excited about it um but
if it's just like an ice cream ice cream
i like the one that's the pistachio but
it doesn't have pistachios in it it has
roasted almonds because i think that
that tastes better but mostly it's
anything from yogurtland i can get down
on yeah yeah yeah i i really like i mean
if it's a really good like i i like you
know it's i like a lot of toppings and
candy and whatever like exactly what
you're saying but if it's a really good
ice cream uh i do really like coffee
flavored ice cream so like mcconnell's
that place from santa barbara
they have a really amazing coffee ice
cream that's that's probably my favorite
was it like van something something they
have like this earl grey yeah
it does a really good one that yeah it's
like van luin or something and lewin
yeah they do a really good earl grey
okay i'm hungry now so i'm gonna wrap
this up um we will be back next week uh
i know we talked about doing something
in a uh trap house this week but next
week we're moving to the crack house so
there's a clue yeah
there's a clue uh it should be a fun one
and yeah plus it's a movie i like next
week so
what a change
exciting very excited to to bring you uh
our
spectacular next week so we'll see you
then thanks for joining us australia
commentaries bye-bye
[Music]
you